mais souvent on a des problèmes on les
comprend pas vos textos pas du tout je
suis atelier regarder si vous voulez
c'est pourquoi il a écrit ça à d'autres
gens m'avaient envoyé merci 7 pour ton
gentil massage
tu vois 6 voilà ça c'est ce [ __ ] de
correcteurs en plus je trouve pas les
ponctuations je me retrouve avec des
dépôts tout débile cicéron jaune qu'a
été tire la langue avec des lunettes de
soleil aux mollets ça ouais voilà les
dessins
[Musique]
avec la surprise du marié terminé on en
voit d'ailleurs regarde un peu ton
portable à la main comme sa voix je
t'appelle et je te le dis qu ou juste un
texto non
c'est trop risqué a bien sûr d'accord
vous aviez sûrement texto ah oui mais je
vous avais pris les oui vous m'avez
écrit des vous arrivez vous me demandez
et puis je viendrai vous lécher tout de
suite non en plus de quelques uns se
trouve ça c'est mon correcteur à c'est
ce que j'ai pensé comme on se connaît
pas bien
mais non ce qu'on n'est pas bien
[Musique]